for 13 years jamie spears has had almost
total control of his daughter's life it
made him a villain in the eyes of many
of her fans but now he says he's ready
to let go
britney spears had long made it clear
she wanted her father removed as
conservator an arrangement she said had
ruined her life and even prevented her
from having more children
[Applause]
it was the singer's impassioned plea to
a judge in june as fans outside strained
to listen in to an audio feed that
confirmed what they'd been saying for
years
she told the court the conservatorship
was abusive that she felt like a slave
she was traumatized she said she
supported the movement that had grown in
their words to free brittany
jamie spears has always denied the
allegations she made and said he only
ever acted in his daughter's best
interest in their filing to the court
his lawyers said as mr spears has said
again and again all he wants is what is
best for his daughter if ms spears wants
to terminate the conservative ship and
believes that she can handle her own
life mr spears believes that she should
get that chance
it will still be up to the judge to
officially end the conservatorship
the court imposed the conservatorship so
only the court can remove it
certainly it helps if jamie spears is
saying that he'll
support ending the conservatorship that
should be smooth sailing now to end the
conservatorship after all these years
but there are going to be accounting
issues that have to be dealt with with
all of the
compensation that mr spears is asking
for and other details so it won't just
simply end but this is a very positive
development it appears at last she's
getting her wish greg milam sky news los
angeles